[Musik]
wenn die schwarzen vollständig
ausgerottet werden stünde die menschheit
vor dem gleichen problem mit denen sie
konfrontiert wäre wenn die schwarzen als
menschen anerkannt und integriert würden
die menschheit würde aufhören zu
existieren
da sie ihre begriffliche karenz verlöre
weil sie ihr mindestens stück verloren
hätte die minimalanforderung eines
kontrast die schwarze person wird
benötigt um die grenzen der menschlichen
subjektivität zu markieren diese
gedanken stammt von frank peterson dem
dritten er wurde 1956 in new orleans
geboren und ist professor für african
american studies an der university of
california in irvine
aufgeschrieben hat er diese einsicht in
seinem buch afro pessimismus
was alles hinter dieser bezeichnung
steckt was aus ihr folgt und was einen
afro pessimisten auszeichnet das werden
wir in den kommenden minuten erörtern
mein name ist khan schwanke und als gast
der heutigen folge des faz bücher
podcasts darf ich wolfgang matz begrüßen
er ist literaturwissenschaftler und
übersetzer und arbeitete 25 jahre als
lektor beim hanser verlag in münchen
guten tag herr maz guttenberg man könne
ja afro pessimismus was genau verbirgt
sich hinter diesem label ja aus dem
zitat am anfang hat man ja schon eine
sehr sehr starke these herausgelesen an
ein zitat war wirklich sehr prägend für
dieses buch ist alles sehr sehr gut
ausgesucht es ist eine radikale theorie
über es schwarz sein über den rassismus
es ist gleichzeitig eine
autobiografische sichtweise und eine
theoretische
es gibt von dem wirklich radikalen
gedanken aus der in diesem zitat ja
schon heraus kam der schwarze sei kein
mensch und das von einem schwarzen
theoretiker ausgesprochen der
schwarzwald kein mensch weil er in dem
begriff der menschheit die in der
europäisch geprägte humanismus
entwickelt hat nicht hineingehört eine
in der tat äußerst radikale these die
kriege ich auch sehr viel ablehnung
erfahren hat aber von ihm in seinem buch
finde ich auf eine weise vertreten wird
die
unbedingt vor auseinander setzung
herausfordert nun stehen in diesem buch
tatsächlich setzte bei denen man
schlucken muss ja radikal zugespitzten
thesen beispielsweise sagt wilders ein
schwarzes kleid lassen sich mit keinem
anderen leid analogie sieren also nicht
mit dem leiter native americans nicht
mit dem leid der juden nicht mit dem
leid ausgebeuteter asiaten und sofort
also er schreibt ich zitiere mal native
americans sind wahrhaftig menschen in
empirischer hinsicht bedroht ihre
auslöschung nicht die stabilität der
menschheit genauso wenig wie die
antisemitische gewalt des holocaust die
menschheit unverständlich gemacht hätte
wenn der holocaust die jüdinnen
ausgelöst hätte wie weit können sie
hamas oder möchten sie diese
argumentation folgen ja wieviel jetzt
ganz direkt in die wirklich schweren
probleme hinein gegangen was auch damit
zu tun hat mit der frage wie weit diese
theorie eine kritik eingeht zulässt wir
kennen das heute das kritik sozusagen
nur von selbst betroffenen geäußert
werden sollte und das ist natürlich hier
wissen wenn wir darüber reden gar nicht
der fall ich würde diese thesen die sie
jetzt skizziert haben natürlich nicht in
jeder weise unterschreiben
es ist aber glaube ich auch gar nicht in
jeder hinsicht die frage die sie dem
leser dieses buches stellt wäre dann
selbst sagt an mehreren stellen dass
afro pessimismus
eine optische linse sei es ein zitat
oder ein mittel zu interpretation
als werkzeug zu verstehen das heißt das
thema um das es geht die idee frage der
unterdrückung der schwarzen jetzt
zunächst mal vornehmlich in den
vereinigten staaten in amerika und wenn
man sie unter dieser linse betrachtet
unter dieser radikalen voraussetzung
dann kommt tatsächlich etwas dabei
heraus ob das jetzt im vergleich zb
mit dem antisemitismus tatsächlich
stimmt ist dann eine frage die man in
der tat sehr intensiv erörtern kann aber
das buch von von wilson und er selber
wird sich diese diskussion ganz sicher
nicht verweigern es ist keine
hermetische theorie sieht die sagt
stimme mir zu oder stimmen wir nicht zu
ich habe es auch immer so verstanden
mittel zur interpretation heißt ich sehe
mir die verhältnisse einmal unter dieser
linse an
und benutzten es als werkzeug
um die diskussion damit in gang zu
setzen
hatten sie denn bei der lektüre dieses
buchs das gefühl einiges besser
verstanden zu haben beispielsweise mit
blick auf strukturelle gewalt gegen
schwarze unbedingt unbedingt er zitiert
ja auch viele sehen er beschreibt die
autographe autobiografische sehen wo man
auch geneigt sein könnte einfach zu
sagen na gut das ist schlimm aber es
gibt auch andere situationen bessere
situationen dass man es sozusagen als
individuelle verfehlungen von einzelnen
personen nur ansieht in seiner
darstellung bekommt das eine eine
schärfe und die ist einfach hinaus hebt
über den anekdotischen moment
da gibt es ziemlich viele dieser szenen
und und die reichen tatsächlich von der
fahrt im taxi zum flughafen ist hin auch
zu einer konferenz die sich ausdrücklich
mit rassistischen verhaltensweisen
beschäftigt und wo er dann in der
nacherzählung aufsehen kommt wo in der
tat andere gruppen die sich als
rassistisch verfolgte ansehen dem
schwarzen gegenüber noch einmal eine
ebenso unannehmbare haltung einnehmen
also da gibt es 40 sehr sehr viele
ansatzpunkte gibt es rein individuelle
erleben in einen zusammenhang setzen
dass man es eben nicht mehr nur als
individuell betrachtet sie sprechen ja
damit auch die die form an dieses ganze
buch hat ja etwas collagen haftet ja
etwas unglaublich sprunghaft ist aber
das funktioniert glaube ich ganz gut
also distanzierte beobachtung stehen
gleichberechtigt neben theoretisch
ausgesprochen anspruchsvollen
überlegungen und passagen in denen in
stil des vollkommen subjektiven memoirs
geschrieben wird in einem kapitel
schildert will das sind wie er und seine
damalige freundin hals über kopf aus der
gemeinsamen wohnung geflohen sind ja
weil sie sich von der regierung verfolgt
fühlen und das hat kompositorisch etwas
enorm filmisches er ist ja auch
filmwissenschaftler und erinnert
künstlerisch im grunde genommen an an
die darstellung wie sie die
kriminalliteratur oder krimis im
fernsehen und im kino vornehmen wie
würden sie herz diese form diese sehr
spezielle form des buchs beschreiben
welche eine der originell sachen daran
man kann ja dieser autobiografischen
momente innerhalb einer theoretischen
text auch sehr kritisch sehen weil
autobiografischen bericht kann man im
prinzip nicht widersprechen wenn der
autor sagt ich habe das so erlebt davon
dass es mir passiert ist kann man nichts
entgegensetzen man kann damit natürlich
so eine theorie auch immunisierung gegen
widerspruch aber gerade das tut ja schon
gar nicht er springt dann in ganz andere
sprache register hinüber manchmal auch
in universitäre sprach register wo man
tatsächlich auch mal zwischendurch den
kopf schütteln und sagt das hätte man
auch ein bisschen weniger kompliziert
sagen können aber gerade dieser kontrast
finde ich mache die sache so
herausfordernd denn gerade die
autobiografischen passagen sind
natürlich ausgesprochen stadt ja diese
sache wird mit der wohnung aber auch
erfahrungen in südafrika er war mitglied
in der sonnen mandela im widerstand
gegen die apartheid das macht den großen
reiz dieses buches aus dieser wechsel
dieser kontrast und ich hatte für mich
immer ein ganz starken eindruck dass
tiere beiden seiten sich gegenseitig
sehr stark befruchten und und verstärken
ist insofern die wir sagen jetzt mal
theorie des afro pessimismus als reine
theorie überhaupt denkbar oder braucht
die notwendigerweise das persönliche
erleben wahrscheinlich braucht wird als
reine theorie würde man natürlich auch
viele fragen an sie stellen wir haben ja
am anfang schon die wichtigsten fragen
schon genannt stimmt das wirklich dass
der humanistische begriff menschen
zwangsläufig auf den schwarzen
angewiesen ist da kann man historische
fragen stellen hat es dieses gegen bild
der schwarzen zu der zeit als der
humanismus entstanden ist tatsächlich in
der form schon gegeben oder man kann die
frage stellen was ist denn mit
gesellschaften die keine
nennenswerte präsenz von schwarzen bei
sich haben aber diese fragen sind auch
sehr sehr wichtig diese fragen stellen
sich tatsächlich aber es zeigt sich
daran auch dass die theorie entwickelt
eben diesen reinen erfahrungshintergrund
tatsächlich braucht glaube ich und das
würde er vermutlich auch sagen es ist
keine hermetische geschlossene theorie
die sagt so und so ist die welt bestellt
in diesem ausgrenzung mechanismen
sondern es ist ein wechselspiel was
entweder beim zuhörer oder leser eine
ganz massive gegenreaktion hervor ruft
er berichtet selber davon dass das auch
auf konferenzen und so weiter oft
geschehen ist und wenn es nicht den
großen widerspruch hervor ruft dann wäre
es so dass es eben diese hoffentlich
produktive diskussion hervor ruft er
rekurriert ja immer in dem buch auf
seine eigene biografie erhebt hervor er
sei max ist er sei kommunist erhebt
hervor wo sein denken eigentlich
herkommt folgt der afro pessimismus
notwendig da raus aus kritischer theorie
marxismus kommunismus oder steht er in
einer anderen möglicherweise komplett
entgegengesetzten denktradition ich hab
dafür ausgebaut den ausdruck der wilden
denkens er nimmt im grunde seine
werkzeuge wo er sie braucht natürlich
greift er auf bestimmte marxistische
theorie elemente zurück was bei einem
solchen verständnis von unterdrückung
wir auch naheliegt ich glaube gar nicht
dass zwangsläufig er das bräuchte
er klickt fc marl wir haben noch einen
begriff gar nicht hereingenommen der für
ihn sehr sehr wichtiges nämlich den der
sklaven ja bereits er sagt er schwarze
ist in die weltgeschichte
erst als klar war eingetreten
schwarze gibt es in der europäisch
geprägten weltgeschichte erst sehen sie
als sklaven instrumentalisiert worden
sind da spricht einiges dafür dass diese
erklärung einen sinn hat und
selbstverständlich könnte man da sagen
dass man gegenüber dem phänomen der
sklaverei mit einem marxistischen
instrumentarium eventuell ganz gut
zurecht kommt brauchen tut er es meiner
ansicht nach nicht unbedingt aber das
ist dieses jahr würde denken dass er
dort vorher es gebrauchen kann
psychoanalyse benutzt für es gebrauchen
kann struktur realistische theorie
elemente und eben auch wie gesagt aus
der alten marxistischen theorie stande
elemente aber er setzt sie zusammen zu
etwas was dann eben tatsächlich nur
seine eigene theorie
wie sie sagen er sagte es gibt keine
schwarze zeit die derzeit der der
sklaverei vorausgeht das heißt ja der
erfahrungsraum der sklaverei ist immer
die grundlage für den erwartungshorizont
der dann auch von der sklaverei
beherrscht sein wird und das schreibt er
immer wieder er benutzt sehr viele
metaphern er benutzt sehr viel bilder
die funktionieren unterschiedlich gut
aber was letztlich am ende dabei
rauskommt ist es gibt keine erlösung für
schwarze person würden sie das als
befund
als leser unterstreichen oder sehen sie
doch noch wenn sie dieses buch zu lesen
irgendwo möglichkeiten der hoffnung ja
da wird natürlich der springende punkt
am ende so wie er es darstellt ist die
eigentliche konsequenz dieses problem
des rassismus gegen schwarze sei
schlechterdings unlösbar und da ist
natürlich die antwort von jemandem der
politisch aktiv ist der politisch am
leben steht kann ja nur sein aber das
darf nicht sein weil man kann in dieser
frage ja nicht einfach resignieren am
ende und das deutet er auch an ist das
natürlich wird diese philosophische
theorie sie sang zurecht gibt hoffnung
dieses etwas stärker pathetische worte
könnte ganz paradox sagen wenn alle afro
pessimisten würden und diese situation
ein sehen wir dann dann wäre die sache
ja gelöst weil das bewusstsein von
dieser unlösbaren situation allen
gemeinsam wäre ich glaube diese letzte
frage den will dann vielleicht gar nicht
es sehr interessiert weil auch er wird
sicher nicht auf die resignative pointe
zurückziehen es sei halt nun einfach
unlösbar er sagt an einer stelle dass es
auch so ein erfahrungsbericht wo ihn
jemand danach fragt und sagt naja so
dank die liberalen illusionen kritisiert
und auch sozusagen das reine gefühl wir
seien mit euch jetzt solidarisch mit
euch schwarzen und er sagte naja es gibt
doch eine form von solidarität zum
beispiel dass wir hier zusammensitzen in
diesem seminar und darüber diskutieren
selbst kontrovers ist ja schon eine form
von solidarität schreibt er an einer
stelle
also ich hatte ein bisschen er wohl auch
den ausdruck kritische theorie ich hatte
es ein bisschen auch erinnert es gibt
von dem deutschen philosophen der
kritischen theorie von max horkheimer
gibt diese äußerungen die er mehrmals
gemacht hat was ist die kritische
theorie wie es pessimistisch in der
theorie und optimistisch in der praxis
das heißt die kritische theorie war ja
in dem wettlauf gegenüber auch nicht
gerade optimistisch aber im politischen
im alltäglichen handeln muss man
natürlich trotzdem optimistisch sein die
konsequenz die sache ist unlösbar also
lassen wir erst mal dabei kann es ja
nicht sein und auch er selber als also
ihr sohn als aktivist handelt er selber
auch nicht so wenn er gegen
polizeigewalt
demonstriert dann handelt er ja auch
nicht so dass er sagt die rache ist und
lösbar ja wo sie polizeigewalt sagen
gewalt spielt eine zentrale rolle in dem
buch nicht nur gewalt gegen schwarze
sondern gewalt
allgemeinwohl dass er glaubt ja das ist
durch ausreichend auf ruhe in den
straßen durch brennende polizeistation
durch mobilisierung sagte dass man in
einem interview durch leid unterweisen
progressiven dazu kommen könnte dass
kosmetische veränderungen geschehen wie
beurteilen sie sein verhältnis zu gewalt
das hat mit ihrer vorstellung von
kosmetischen veränderungen natürlich zu
tun also man muss dazu sagen dass bisher
geschrieben vor den letzten massiven
form von polizeigewalt in amerika haben
die dann zu den bekannten folgen ja auch
geführt haben er sieht natürlich vor
allen dingen zunächst die gewalt den die
schwarzen ausgesetzt sind und
die ganze diskussion über gewalt führt
er natürlich unter dieser voraussetzung
dh die alltägliche polizeigewalt
gegenüber schwarzen uns nur gegenüber
armen schwarzen denn das macht diese
strukturelle gewalt für ihn aus und
unter diesen voraussetzungen hält er
sozusagen die liberalen illusion die man
sozusagen ein bisschen ironisch
charakterisieren kann seid nett
zueinander also verbessert einfach diese
verhältnisse das hält er für illusionär
und
das sozusagen die punktuelle gegen
gewalt daran auch nichts ändert ist
denke ich für ihn ebenso klar aber er
würde ganz sicher nicht eine wirklich
strukturelle gegen gewalt als illegitim
ansehen das glaube ich nicht die gewalt
geht ja bei ihm quasi bis in den ganz
persönlichen bereich hinein er
verheiratet mit einer weißen frau und er
sagt man müsse es so charakterisieren er
ist der sklave sie ist seine herrin ja
das sind ja unglaubliche thesen also
beim lesen schlug man ja schon beim
lesen schluckt man schon da er ja so
autobiografisch schreibt fragt man sich
dann natürlich ja wir machen die beiden
das genau dass sie trotzdem
zusammenleben die frage ist natürlich
für den leser des buches ich wirklich
beantwortbar aber wenn man jetzt wieder
es so macht wie er es ja erwartet dass
man die theorie sozusagen als werkzeug
benutzt als optische linse jetzt stelle
man sich mal vor da ist dieses ehepaar
muss her gar nicht er und seine frau
seien aber da ist dieses ehepaar
schwarzer mann weiße frau jetzt stelle
man vs passiert das war es ja auch bei
anderen ehepaaren durchaus häufig
passiert dass es zur trennung kommt und
diese trennungen in
formen eskalieren die man vorher nicht
vorausgesehen hat wenn man das jetzt
unter der these des afro pessimismus
sich anschaut dann muss man eigentlich
auch sagen ja ich werde mir dann auch
ganz klar vorstellen dass plötzlich in
so einem krisen moment an einem wirklich
krassen krisen moment auf einmal dieser
unterschied der rassen unterschied in
der hautfarbe auf einmal auch zur waffe
wird ja wenn man sich das wenn man sich
das vor stellt man sich also ein paar
hollywood filme über rosenkriege
anschauen was in so einer
extremsituation
gegenüber dem anderen und der anderen
als psychische waffe eingesetzt wird
dann kann man sich sehr wohl vorstellen
dass plötzlich dieser rassen unterschied
dort ganztags wieder hervortritt weil
sie erreichte im alltagsleben solange
die beiden sich verstehen nur im
hintergrund ist aber wahrscheinlich ist
dass die idee die dahinter steht dass
der rasen unterschied auch dort bei
menschen die sich auf die ein oder
andere weise offensichtlich nahe sind
und miteinander leben können nie
wirklich verschwinden kann das ist es
vermutlich warten jetzt in dem fall die
lehre des afro pessimismus faire und da
hat ja auch was plausibel
man müsste ja fast noch weiter gehen und
sagen dass man sich von dem wort
rassismus was im afro pessimismus
eigentlich nur unzureichend ist
verabschieden müsste also eigentlich ist
gewalt gegen schwarze ja keine form von
rassistischem hass sagt er sondern das
genom der menschlichen erneuerung das
heißt ein therapeutikum für alle anderen
menschen und hat der afro pessimismus
insofern das zeug in der rassismus
debatte so etwas wie ein
paradigmenwechsel herbeizuführen
ganz bestimmt in dem sinne dass der
begriff rassismus den ich im song
zusammenhang auch nur noch sehr zögernd
verwenden würde man hat so schnell kein
anderes wort der begriff des rassismus
macht so viele sachen gleich die nähere
betrachtung es gar nicht unbedingt sind
und er selber widerspricht dem ja auch
in dem er sagt der rassismus produkte
stehen ausprobieren der sitz muss denen
andere minorität
gesellschaftsgruppen erleiden ist etwas
anderes als das was die schwarzen
erleiden und wie gesagt das kann der
ausgangspunkt sein dass man versucht
sich noch intensiver einmal mit dieser
frage zu beschäftigen
aber tatsächlich führt der begriff des
rassismus an der stelle einfach nicht
weiter der reichten nicht mehr aus wie
schätzen sie herr maz insgesamt die
zukunft dieses auch sein könnte es so
was wie ein klassiker werden ich glaube
schon also ich habe lange nicht gelesen
zu diesem thema was mir derart starken
eindruck gemacht hat und es lässt hat
auch bestimmte eben doch allzu weiche
themen hinter sich also als sozusagen
die idee die liberale illusion es reiche
doch nur den weißen irgendwie ein
bisschen klar zu machen wo sie sich im
alter trotzdem rassistisch benehmen und
dann werden sie jeweils einige von ihnen
vielleicht auch mehr wie einfach schon
etwas besser
diese liberale illusion ist nach diesem
buch eigentlich überhaupt nicht alt war
auch in dem sinne dass er ja darauf
investiert das eben auch liberale weise
im prinzip diese anti schwarze haltung
ob sie wollen oder nicht trotzdem so
reproduzieren weil sie eben einfach zu
ihrem begriff der menschheit essen was
ein mensch es dazugehört man kann das
nicht einfach durch ein bisschen
pädagogik aus sich heraus reinigen und
dann ist man auf der richtigen seite
insofern wenn man diese thesen ernst
nimmt haben wir nachher schwer dahinter
zurück und auf schwächere theorien
wieder zurückzugehen von daher glaube
ich wirklich dass dieses buch ein ganz
ganz wichtiger meilenstein der die
diskussion darüber deutlich verändern
muss franco will dass ein afro
pessimismus aus dem englischen von jan
wilm erschien bei matthes & seitz vielen
dank wolfgang s
wir beschließen die heutige folge mit
drei tipps ich habe drei kollegen
gebeten in aller kürze jeweils ein
sachbuch zu empfehlen dass ihnen in den
letzten wochen besonders gut gefallen
hat hier kommt die ausbeute ich bin
peter hahne ich bin redakteurin des
films in berlin und ich empfehle der
mensch und das biest von richard
goerlich erschienen bei rowohlt berlin
ich empfehle es weil das die
umfassendste darstellung das verhältnis
von mensch und tier ist die mir bislang
begegnet ist weil es ein sehr lesbarer
von anekdoten bersten der schmöker ist
vor allem aber weil das in seiner
komprimiert haid die 10.000 jahre
umspannt eine kontinuität auch zeigt die
ebenso aufschlussreich wie erschreckend
ist immer schon hat sich der mensch für
diese anderen lebewesen interessiert die
mit ihm den planeten bewohnen er sich
gefragt warum sie eigentlich da sind wie
nah sie und sind und immer schon hat der
tiere trotzdem vor allem auch ihren
nutzwert beurteilt und dementsprechend
behandelt mit dem ergebnis dass 90
prozent aller säugetiere die in diesem
moment auf der erde leben da sind um von
uns gegessen zu werden und eine million
tierarten vom aussterben bedroht sind
wenn man fertig ist mit dem buch hat man
verstanden dass ich etwas ändern muss im
endspiel verhältnis darum ist es trotz
seines historischen ansatzes auch sehr
aktuell
mein name ist philipp crone ich bin
redakteurin der wirtschaftsredaktion
aber auch ein großer musikliebhaber und
schreibe deswegen ab und zu mal auch
musik rezensionen für das foto zuletzt
habe ich gelesen future sounds von
christoph dallach darin beschreibt er
wie ein paar krautrock die pop welt
revolutionierte für mich einen wirklich
extrem inspirieren das buch weil er mit
allen menschen aus der deutschen
krautrock szene gesprochen hat die
wichtig sind und die zum zeitpunkt der
recherche noch lebten und die ihm
wirklich tiefe einblicke vermittelt
haben das was diese musikrichtung
ausgemacht hat es ist verfasst als oral
history liest sich unglaublich spannend
und war bei mir tatsächlich so dass ich
das bis in die nacht hinein gelesen habe
dass mich so gefesselt hat davon zu
hören wie man sozusagen ohne eine alte
tradition eine neue rockmusik erschafft
die aber auch nicht an den
amerikanischen musiktradition anknüpft
eine absolute empfehlung ist erschienen
im suhrkamp verlag und kostet 18
hallo ich bin sie behandle ich bin
astrophysikerin und redakteurin im
wissenschaftsressort der faz eine
leseempfehlung ist das ende von allem
astrophysikalische betrachtet
geschrieben ist das von der
amerikanischen kosmologen katie mac
erschienen bei piper für 22 euro das
braucht es behandelt die frage wie unser
universum im ganzen irgendwann zu ende
gehen würde das ist natürlich eine große
frage die wir heute nicht mit sicherheit
beantworten können zu der es aber im
rahmen unserer physikalischen theorien
einige spekulation und hypothesen gibt
und diese verschiedenen spekulationen
die stellt katie mac in ihrem buch vor
also zum beispiel könnte es sein dass
das universum irgendwann wieder
kollabiert es könnte sein dass es sich
einfach immer weiter ausdehnt sowie sich
momentan auch schon ausdehnt das ist
aber immer lehrer und immer gleich über
mega wird es könnte auch sein dass das
universum irgendwann von der dunklen
energie die für diese ausbildung
verantwortlich ist zerrissen wird oder
unser universum könnte auch mit einem
anderen universum korrigieren und
dadurch zu ende gehen das klingt alles
sehr abgedreht das ist es auch aber wenn
man sich für solche themen interessiert
dann macht das trotzdem so viel spaß
dieses buch zu lesen erstens weil katy
max sehr unterhaltsam schreibt und
zweitens weil man neben all diesen doch
relativ unsicheren spekulationen
gleichzeitig sehr viel über die moderne
empirische kosmologie lernt
in den charts und auf unserer seite
faz.net / bücher - podcast bücher mit
finden sie besprechungen zu den titeln
die gerade erwähnt worden sind wenn sie
fragen oder anmerkungen zu dieser folge
haben können sie mir gerne schreiben die
e-mail-adresse lautet bücher - podcast
faz.de bücher mit natürlich können sie
unserem podcast auch abonieren licon und
mit sternchen belohnen in der nächsten
folge wird es weihnachtlich andrea
diener und fridtjof küchemann sprechen
mit alina bronsky über ihre beiden neuen
bücher vielen dank fürs zuhören und auch
bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]